ona diana manas lé chef de cabinet et
porte parole du président de l'union des
forces démocratiques de guinée l'ufdg
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors cellou dalein diallo
dénonce des irrégularités pendant le
scrutin qui s'est déroulé hier nickel ou
pouvez-vous vous en dire plus alors je
commencerai d'abord par saluer la
mobilisation historique du peuple de
guinée
la maturité démocratique dont ils ont
fait preuve hier et tous les
observateurs sont unanimes pour noter
longuement avec lequel les guinéennes et
guinéens ont voté et c'est engouement
est quelque part un révélateur d'une
volonté de rupture
une volonté de rupture avec un pouvoir
qui en dix ans n'a pas tenu ses
promesses en pouvoir dans le bilan se
caractérise par la détérioration des
conditions de vie des populations par le
chômage endémique des jeunes par une
corruption endémique par le désordre de
nos institutions et surtout par le recul
de l'état de droit et des violations
massives des droits de l'homme
unanimement condamné par les
organisations de défense de droits de
l'homme
alors est-ce qu'il faut dire à ce stade
c'est que il nous a été signalé
délimité de deux changements et de
manipulation des résultats dans le
pouvoir dans le parti présidentiel est
friand on note dans certaines
circonscriptions des substitutions et
falsification de deux procès-verbaux
dans certaines circonscriptions
mais toujours est il est monsieur cellou
dalein diallo et va le rappeler le
pouvoir en place n'a pas des lecteurs
mais dispose d'une armée de fraudeurs
mais peu importe le niveau de la fraude
ne pourront pas évidemment passer ça
c'est certain
alors ce n'est pas la première fois que
cellou dalein diallo affronte alpha
condé 2010-2015 pourquoi aujourd'hui ce
serait différent pourquoi pourrait-il
gagner mais aujourd'hui ce serait
différent parce que monsieur alpha condé
ton candidat par effraction madame c'est
un candidat par effraction je vous
rappelle que c'est un candidat qui ont
organisé un référendum son clan pour
changer la constitution pour s'accorder
à 83 ans la possibilité de briguer un
troisième mandat lors qu'il en est il a
physiquement et intellectuellement et
aujourd'hui madame laissez moi vous
témoigner de la ferveur populaire qui
accueillit cellou dalein diallo à
l'intérieur du pays on a en la syrie
tous les amants tous les villages
reculés de la guinée et on a senti en
contact de ces populations là une réelle
volonté de rupture et la présence n'est
que lorsque l'on quitte l'intérieur du
pays pour regagner la capitale conakry
nous avons été accueillis triomphalement
par plus de deux millions de personnes
alors que monsieur alpha condé pemet à
réunir dans mille personnes dans un
stade donc une volonté de lassitude de
la part des guinéens qui sont axées b et
qui sont hautes d'une alternative est la
seule alternative crédible qui vaille
c'est celle qui incarne celle qu'incarne
pardon monsieur cellou dalein diallo
alors monsieur cellou dalein diallo
justement s'il est élu quelle sera sa
priorité je parle des prochains mois des
prochains moins de sa gouvernance que
fera t-il pour la guinée alors alors
avant de rentrer évidemment dont les
dans les préoccupations de monsieur
cellou dalein diallo j'aimerais vous
dire au stade actuel que les résultats
issus des urnes que nous avons reçus des
bureaux de vote donnent cellou dalein
diallo en tête sur l'ensemble du
territoire national c'est important de
noter cette information alors je peux
vous dire madame que monsieur cellou
dalein diallo aura à coeur la
refondation de notre état il appellera
des réformes profondes pour la justice
les forces de sécurité l'administration
et monsieur cellou dalein diallo a tort
de constituer un gouvernement qui sera
ouvert à toutes les forces politiques à
la société civile en général et c'est
super tu as juste cet état impartial et
stable en l'état rassemblés sur lui même
dont on a besoin pour me trompe ou se
mettre en mouvement sur le chemin du
progrès et et et si vous permettait
madame l'une de ses priorités c'est la
réconciliation nationale la guinée a
connu une histoire absolument
douloureuse de violations des droits de
l'homme va donc mettre en oeuvre les
recommandations de la commission de
réflexion sur la réconciliation
nationale afin que les guinéens se
retrouvent regarde leur histoire en face
et il a eu alors
at il manque de poigne mais s'agira pas
d'une chasse aux sorcières il ne s'agira
pas de vengeance
il s'agira de pardon d'acceptation il
s'agira de justice et s'agira de faire
en sorte aussi que des secteurs d'avenir
tels que l'éducation la santé
l'agriculture et la nécessité de réduire
la pauvreté soit traité au premier rang
des préoccupations et là ce que vous
dire aussi madame que la jeunesse est au
centre de ses préoccupations que notons
aujourd'hui la jeunesse guinéenne au
foot de perspectives le la guinée le
deuxième pays pourvoyeurs de demandeurs
d'asile derrière l'afghanistan et de
tout premier pour ce qui concerne les
demandeurs d'asile nous pensons que la
guinée mérite mieux
et quand je pense qu'ils voulaient
d'image qui nous sont parvenues depuis
leur vous avez vu ce geste ce geste
symbolique de monsieur cellou dalein
diallo indiquant qu'il est l'heure et
madame je puis vous assurer que l'heure
de l'alternance démocratique a sonné et
justement quelle que soit l'issue du
scrutin est ce que vous craignez à des
violences on perd de tension en guinée
à ce stade je pense qu'il est
fondamental de rappeler que la parole à
partir de hao peu plus de qui est madame
qu'il n'acceptera pas qu'il n'acceptera
pas qu'on lui vole sa victoire et qui
prendra ses responsabilités vous-même
l'adedy vous l'avez mentionné monsieur
cellou dalein diallo est un républicain
il appelait à la retenue
mais écoutez on s'est tous en 2010 peu
le scénario qui s'est passé 2020 des
trappes à 2010 encore moins 2015 nous
n'avons jamais été aussi près que de
l'aide que nous l'étions en 2010 en 2015
donc c'est au pouvoir que le pouvoir de
faire en sorte que la vérité des urnes
ne s'impose à vous touche
nadiana man merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes chef
de cabinet porte parole du président de
l'union des forces démocratiques de
guinée l'ufdg merci d'avoir été avec mon
conte direct sur arte france